earlier this week the young Democratic
socialists circulated a petition begging
the administration to disinvite me from
campus here tonight they they did this
because I apparently threatened quote
the lives of trans and all Queer people
in their words I am calling for a
genocide of trans people
this was news to me of course a Twitter
person by the name of Kate Craig she
describes herself as a quote former
Tennessee Senate candidate activist
organizer writer photographer Animal
Rescuer she's very busy she's up to a
lot of things
she said that I quote literally called
for Trans people to be exterminated
I'm not sure when I literally did that
but
Katie Craig says so so I guess I must
have she went on she said quote there's
nothing civil about him he has called
for violence and we don't need someone
calling for violence in our community
these claims in this petition it came as
a big relief to me because they relieved
me of the responsibility of writing a
speech
because these claims themselves proved
the thesis of my talk here tonight which
is that the left bereft of facts and
arguments hoaxes its way to power
it does it does
this is not a recent phenomenon
the libs have been using this tactic of
claiming violent threats where none
exist especially on University campuses
since at least the 1960s since that time
violence has occasionally broken out on
campus in virtually every case it has
been the leftists committing the
violence this really all began around
1969 up at Cornell when rifle wielding
student activists stormed and occupied
Cornell's Willard straight Hall some of
the more senior people in the audience
tonight might remember that event the
student radicals kicked out parents who
had been visiting their children the
armed occupiers demanded the creation of
an Africana studies department and they
Justified their occupation of the
building on the grounds that there was a
burning cross the previous night outside
of the black women's Cooperative on
campus
but there was something that didn't
quite add up about that burning cross
you see the Ithaca Police were never
able to track down those elusive cross
burners
in fact they suspected that members of
the Afro-American Society themselves set
the blaze to justify further protests
this is a suspicion that one of the
group's members later confirmed Stephen
Goodwin who served as a treasurer for
the Afro-American society called the
cross burning a setup
turns out the the society contrived The
hoax according to Goodwin quote to bring
more media and more attention to the
whole thing and it worked
the activists got what they wanted
so leftist activists ever since bereft
of any real grievance have followed the
same strategy of inventing imaginary
oppression to advance their interests in
retrospect it is unbelievable that
anybody believed jussie Smollett
you remember that
Jesse Smollett a little-known actor
claimed that two Trump hat wearing
conservative Republicans not only
recognized him but chased him down
beat him up and very gently laid a noose
around his neck all while chanting this
is Maga country in downtown Chicago
a city that has been governed
exclusively by democrats since 1931.
plenty of people actually believed it
including the current President and Vice
President of the United States who
called it an attempted modern day
lynching
and the sandwich survived that's true
that was the Silver Lining in that
incident of Terror
now when it became clear that smilet had
staged the whole thing himself liberals
tried to downplay the episode after
they'd spent two weeks trying to turn it
into a national news story liberals
insisted that while the smallet incident
might have been a hoax
that it got to a greater truth that's
what they always say they say I know we
got caught in a lie but my lie it speaks
to a greater truth somewhere somehow I
don't know how
the greater truth it spoke to was the
real epidemic
of hate crimes this Nationwide epidemic
of Terror targeting any and all of the
Liberals favored identity groups
but there isn't one time and time again
the incidents that liberals tout is
justification for advancing their
political agenda on Race on sex on
everything turn out to be hoaxes it's
all Jessie Smollett it is Jesse Smith
all the way down especially on campuses
in 2016 three black students accused an
Ohio bakery owner named Alan Gibson of
racial profiling Oberlin faculty staff
and administrators immediately began to
protest the university canceled its
contracts with Gibson's Food Mart the
business was ruined and the owner was
branded a racist the worst thing you can
possibly be called today
in reality Gibson had caught the
students attempting to steal liquor from
the store the ringleader later admitted
as much
unfortunately that hoax had a relatively
happy ending in that an Ohio jury
eventually awarded Gibson's Bakery more
than 36 million dollars from Oberlin
they just bankrupted
that University
it should have gone a little further
than they might have actually bankrupted
it but the paycheck came too late for
Alan Gibson who died during the years
that the case was still in litigation
on the very same day that the Oberlin
students slandered Gibson as a bigot
Bowling Green State student Elisha long
claimed to have been attacked by Rock
hurling white Trump supporters instantly
you know what happened
the school administration sent a long
emotional letter to the students
about the supposed attack the students
began to protest they invade against
racial discrimination the epidemic of
race hate roiling our country in the
wake of Donald Trump's election
and then what happened
same thing that always happens the
student could could not keep her story
straight
and then cell phone records revealed
that she was not even present at the
site of the alleged attack in fact the
only evidence of racism or violence that
investigators found was a trove of text
messages that long had sent to her
boyfriend disparaging white people and
wishing death upon Trump supporters
2017 a black student activist found a
racist threat on her car at Saint Olaf
College in Minnesota it was easy for her
to find the racist threat because she
wrote it herself
that same year five black Air Force
Academy Cadets wrote racial slurs on
their own doors the following November
Finn Arthur a black student at Goucher
College in Maryland wrote I'm going to
kill all
n-i-w-g-e-rs in a dormitory bathroom
when police discovered the true source
of the threatening graffiti
Arthur confessed to having drawn it
himself along with having drawn a
backward swastika apparently Arthur
didn't know what a swastika looks like
and he wrote The Dorm numbers of black
students including his own
he blamed his bottled up anger for
motivating him to commit the hoax
whatever the source of his anger it
could not have been racial bigotry which
was so lacking on campus that he had to
invent some
but what's especially strange about the
case of Finn Arthur is that when you
look at his mug shot you realize
he hardly even looks black
he may have had some black ancestors but
Arthur looks like a white guy making it
even more Preposterous that skinheads
prowling about the campus would have
targeted him for a racial attack hoax
after hoax after improbable hoax
and why
because the ability to claim victimhood
confers power
the power to demand special privileges
the power to upend curricula the power
to pack the University Administration
with diversity equity and inclusion
Deans and other apparatchics and all
sorts of political activists whose sole
job it is to advance the liberal
political project
it doesn't even matter if the incidents
are eventually revealed to be hoaxes one
because the media will suppress the
Revelation they'll run the hoax on page
one and then they'll re-run the
correction and the update on page 1000
but two Because by the time the hoax is
revealed to be a hoax it will have
already had its intended political
effect
the law will have been passed the
bureaucrat will have been installed the
money for the leftist group will have
been raised and then the activists will
just move right along to the next hoax